so look with elections being around the
corner the one topic that keeps coming
up is this minimum wasting $15 an hour
is it a myth is that a propaganda is it
a good thing it sounds noble does it
benefit the younger audience does it
benefit the experienced people does it
benefit larger corporations maybe the
small business owner benefits from this
maybe it's just a benefit for the
government but what is the whole purpose
of this minimum wage is it a myth or
should we really pay attention to so
today in this video I'm going to explain
minimum wage in a complete different way
especially the one topic the next time
somebody owes a politician Republican or
Democrat tells you minimum wage needs to
go up you need to ask a question from
them and see how they'll respond to it
we'll talk about that I'm gonna give you
the cheapest cities in America to live
in the most expensive cities in America
to live in based on the Consumer Price
Index and then on top of that 8 things
you can do to increase your market value
so you don't just make the minimum wage
we start making some real money so
before we get into the first thing I
want to do is I want to study the
history of minimum wage and what kind of
presidents raise the minimum wage more
Democrats more Republicans how did it
work out you're gonna be shell-shocked
what Barack Obama and Ronald Reagan have
income and when it comes out to raising
the minimum wage pretty strange tune but
let's get right into it October 1938 FDR
introduces the minimum wage for the
first time in America 25 cents per hour
which is in today's dollars four dollars
an hour year later he raises it again as
a Democrat racer twice Truman twice as a
Democrat eisenhower once as a Republican
Kennedy twice as a Democrat Johnson
twice as a Democrat Nixon once forth
twice Carter four times during one term
which during his time the economy in
America was in shambles it cost him the
re-election Ronald Reagan gets elected
wins 49 out of 50 states and you ready
Ronald Reagan never once raised minimum
wage and the economy blew up during his
time George Bush Senior raise the
minimum wage twice as a Republican
Clinton twice as a Democrat GW the son
twice as a Republican ready Barack Obama
is the only Democratic president that
was a two-term president who raised the
minimum wage on
since FDR let me say this again he is
the only Democratic president that
raised the minimum wage only once in two
terms in the market still recovered
minimum wage to me as a myth I'll
explain why living wage is math market
value is a path let me explain
minimum wage is a myth how do these
politicians come up with $15 an hour I
actually want to know how did you come
up with it and it's $15 an hour in one
city the same as $15 an hour in another
city watch this
first of all $15 an hour at 40 hours a
week 52 weeks in a year is thirty one
thousand two hundred dollars that's
poverty level is what you're making so
$15 an hour doesn't affect anybody about
do I run a business have nearly a
hundred employees here that work for me
in the state of Texas my minimum wage
for Texas is only 725 there's only two
people I pay less than $15 an hour and
they paid $13 an hour they've only been
with me for 60 days I want talent to
expect more and I want a better pool of
people coming here right but that's a
choice not by force I don't pay 720 I
would never pay 720 because I want my
employees to be able to have a good life
they survive they perform better for me
not by force by choice but watch this
let's talk about this minimum wage 15
times 40 times 60 to 30 $1,200 living
wage is a mathematical formula there's
an organization out there called
Economic Policy Institute epi you can
click on a link below and when you go to
this website you can pick whatever city
you want to live in to find out what is
the living wage cost of living in that
city based on the economy of that city
the cost of living of that city you see
that I trust because it's basic math and
data versus minimum wages $15 an hour
these people we need to pay more it's
not enough pay and some people that are
naive they're like oh my gosh this guy
sounds so noble but in reality whenever
a politician from the left or the right
gets up and just starts throwing numbers
like that out there you know what
they're doing they are questioning our
intelligence and I don't like that and I
don't think you do either
sounds noble but what they're trying to
say is no one's really gonna go out
there and do research and find that it's
really living
wage not minimum wage so let me show you
some data the stick minimum wage and
let's look at the top 10 cities in
America to see how much buying power
your hundred dollar has in these
different cities I got the top ten
cheapest cities in America to limit and
I got the top ten most expensive cities
in America to them and let's take a look
at the cheapest ones
Brown was Ville Texas ready $100 in
Brownsville Texas to go buy what you buy
with $100 the buying power in
Brownsville you only need 85 dollars
because the cost of living there is
fourteen point nine percent below the
market so if you spend a hundred
somewhere you only need 85 over here
okay and then I have the income there
the average incomes thirty four thousand
you know the average home is eighty
three thousand dollars fifteen dollars
an hour in Brownsville you are doing
good you're okay
but not in a different City so Oklahoma
City is at fifteen point one Jonesboro
Arkansas fifteen point five Memphis six
seven Knoxville seventeen point at which
it falls eighteen three you see how this
goes twenty five twenty one point for
convoy 21.8 look at McAllen Texas 23.9%
your hundred dollars the buying power to
match one hundred dollars you need
seventy six dollars in McAllen as you
need a hundred dollars meaning if you go
to dinner the cost transportation
everything together you would need a
hundred dollars in McAllen Texas
you only need seventy six dollars
fifteen dollars an hour in McAllen Texas
you may be rolling you may be having a
comfortable life but let's look at the
top ten most expensive cities in America
ready number ten San Diego cut stead of
living forty-six one you know what it
means
hundred dollars to go to a restaurant in
San Diego it's gonna cost you one
hundred and forty six dollars and ten
cents average home value 488 big
difference between 83 and 488 la 48%
Boston 48 Seattle 49 Oakland 49 5bc 55:7
Brooklyn eighty to one hundred dollars
you need one eighty to Honolulu 88 three
San Francisco 90 to nine ready for
Manhattan now hundred out or dinner you
want to go to and Manhattan's gonna cost
you two hundred thirty eight dollars and
sixty cents let me say that one more
time that same hundred dollar dinner
it's gonna cost you two hundred and
thirty eight dollars and sixty cents the
average home value
Manhattan's 871 thousand dollars ten
times more than the one in Brownsville
Texas so $15 an hour what does it really
mean in Manhattan
I thought these politicians were
brilliant when they would get up and say
$15 SNR is gonna make a big impact
really you know what the rent is in
Manhattan the minimum average rent in is
four thousand five hundred and fifty
nine dollars a month let me say it again
nine dollars a month is rent that's
after taxes that is nearly sixty
thousand dollars just for rent after tax
pre-tax is a hundred thousand dollars
give or take to go grocery shopping in
Manhattan forty percent premium
transportation is thirty percent higher
than any world's movie tickets for you
and your family fifty percent higher so
how did it come up with this minimum
wage number oh it's just a guessing game
there Synder saying what should I say
from stage that's gonna get the vote why
don't you you know because there's more
people that don't make a lot of money
just talk about raising the minimum wage
you'll come across as noble and you care
for people
you can't elect it brilliant idea what
number should I say how about you say
twelve let's say fifteen let's be more
aggressive hey that's awesome
let's do it I think we need to raise the
minimum wage $15 what a noble human
being
let's make you more president and people
fall for 15 bucks an hour who's a really
benefit if we raise the minimum wage you
ready you know how a lot of times you'll
hear politicians say things like Walmart
it's unfair what Walmart is doing
they're putting small business owners
out of business
really Walmart's doing that Amazon it is
unfair what Amazon is doing they're
putting so many small business owners
Rodgers bookstore went out of business
Johnny's liquor store went out of
business Bobby's market went out of
business because of Walmart and Amazon
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute let me ask you a real question
here who can really afford to pay higher
wages if they were to raise the minimum
wage Walmart or Bobby
market okay bobby's market profits ten
grand in a month 20 grand in a month he
can't afford to raise the minimum wage
because he's out of business he's in a
small city Walmart doesn't care every
single time they raise the minimum wage
just so you know Amazon Walmart Apple
Google all these guys are sitting there
saying awesome keep doing it because all
these small business owners are gonna go
out of business and we get them all
because we can afford to race because
all we're gonna do is what you raise
minimum wage we do the basic math this
just dropped off our profits by 4% let's
raise the cost of our product by 4% we
should sell it for $120 now let's set up
$425 Thank You politicians you put out
our competitions you're the best we love
you so much so don't be fooled by next
time when politicians say $15 for the
people $15 and ours is really for the
big corporations very basic math I'm not
telling you anything that sounds out of
the ordinary that's just kind of how
math works so let's talk about the last
of market value this is what I would
like to see our leaders politicians
people running talk about more what do I
need to do to increase my market value
the word I would like to hold our
politicians that are running for office
accountable is not minimum wage I want
to hear your thoughts on living wage I
want to hear your thoughts on market
value so now you're asking what Pat I
want to increase my market value what do
I do
eight things for you to consider number
one skills when it comes up to skill set
you're gonna mean four different
categories which means what anyone can
do what you're doing
which means you're also at the bottom
and you're affected by minimum wage
number two only a few people can do what
you do you're pretty good at it
which means you get paid a little bit
more top 1% you're in the top 1% which
means you get paid good money and you're
the best when you're the best guess what
you do you tell the market what to pay
you because you are the best now a lot
of people would like to get paid with
the top 1% gets paid or the best gets
paid you know what it takes a lot of
sacrifice a lot of hours a lot of
dedication a lot of time away from
family a lot of nights of working late
studying trying to figure out a way to
get better no TV none of this other
stuff taking care of your health
discipline you know who likes doing that
only the top 1% so the top 1% gets paid
what they get paid
they're willing to do what a few and
anyone is not willing to do very simple
by the way say you come to a restaurant
for you and your husband you and your
wife you and your boyfriend/girlfriend
you will understand $200 for dinner are
you okay if I'm winging the chicken and
it's my first day making chicken or
prime rib I don't know how to really
make a bone-in ribeye medium I kind of
can go medium well I don't really know
how long I should put it flip it
seasoning I don't know just a bunch of
salt on it and I'm cooking like anybody
else are you okay
spending $200 for an amateur like me
your answer is what no maybe you said
hell no that's exactly the point so
minimum wage is set up for no reason
if you increase you don't ever worry
about things like this because in a
marketplace you're in the top 1% of
fewer the best now number 2 industry
choose the right industry a lot of
people say noble industry I want to go
do this I want to go do that
I get it it's awesome but if you become
a school teacher teaching fine arts
don't expect to make a quarter-million
dollar your income okay unless if the
Dean is your dad but if you want to try
to do something that's going to make
good money for you you got to look at
industries now you can use your talents
but it's got a bigger upside number
three avoid the passion drug let me
explain what I mean by the passion drug
a lot of these motivational speakers
online people chase your passion go
after your passion you should go after
your passion if you can do this with
this and it's listen all good I'm not
saying anything about passion I have a
completely different mindset with
passion let me explain to what I mean by
passion to me if you're 20 30 40 50 60
70 80 you got to have a game plan this
is my game plan there's four C's you
ought to go through in life there's four
20-year term in your life the first 20
years is curiosity learn go out there
see what people are like learn about
different cultures learn about different
things learn learn learn the first 20 or
you're curious next 20 years career
going to a career where you can make
money money matters money matters a lot
in life who ever tells you money doesn't
matter
they are probably single with no kids
never been marrying them on the home
before money is critical the number one
topic husband and wife argue wants to
have kids is money so if you're single
right now what no kids you better
realize you go on this hot date of yours
with your girl and she looks amazing and
you look hot you got your six-pack I
love her so much you like that tiramisu
let me put it in your mouth let's have
wine do you want to go to my car oh my
gosh
we made out it was so good third-base I
love her mom dad look at this scrum love
to screw here all this other stuff boom
you get married who's paying a bill oh
well my mom makes money and and they
have to pay for it and they covered it
okay
who's paying the rent who's paying a
house how about the bit sex was good but
she's pregnant
ready two hundred fifty thousand dollars
per kid from zero to 18 not including
inflation okay you want to go to
birthday parties you want to try but how
about honey man I thought we got to
travel together oh my gosh this thing's
so expensive money matters money matters
don't let anybody lie to you okay
money matters the next twenty four forty
to sixty can be creative because now
have flexibility you have money
hopefully you've said you can be a
little bit more flexible you can be a
little bit more different right and the
last two this contribution what do you
want to do politics charity go work for
UNICEF you want to go travel the world
go to it contribute as much as you want
Church any of this stuff
you now have done it properly and when
they talk about passion yeah but no idea
how many things I'm passionate about but
I can do it within my vision of the
company I'm building I don't have to
leave that money matters life is
expensive next point number four
specialize don't generalize specialize
number five intrapreneur if you can find
a company that can work with internally
work your butt off go above everybody
else ask for a piece of the company
profit sharing equity and you can be
part of somebody you see that's running
hard and somebody that you know that
person has got a vision they're working
they're going through they're like I can
just hang on to this person's kotel and
make a lot of money you ought to do it
so many times people want to start their
own business I tell them why don't you
go work with somebody and get a piece of
what they're doing and ask them what do
I need to do become an entrepreneur in
an alternative to being an entrepreneur
ten you're trapped don't fall for this
ten you're trap well you know if they've
told me if I work for LAUSD for ten
years I get this ten-year benefit and
they can't ever fire me and I'm just
locked in but you're only making 47
grand a year what are you doing don't
fall for this ten your trap deal that's
gonna make a difference in your life at
all ten your trap is the same trap as a
minimum-wage trap don't fall for it
number seven value value value value
value value the more value you bring to
the world the more people want to do for
you so the more value brink market value
goes up and last but not least
connections in your community let's
when you build a community and you have
the right connections that attracts
money because your market value goes up
if you're rubbing elbows with the right
people somehow someway you end up doing
business with them just today I was
speaking to a guy that runs one of the
biggest speaking companies meaning he
works with all these guys that are
speakers right and we started going
through a list of people and speakers
and he gave me this name and that name
and this name how the hell did this guy
make 1.9 billion dollars
how did that guy make 2.2 billion
dollars he was in the community when
they started a company and he was a guy
that was there for the first seven years
and that's the piece that's what no way
yeah community connections get into
right community and connections and
stick around especially if the people
are drivers there eventually you're
gonna have your break so now you know
how I feel about the minimum wage and
why my thoughts are we ought to be
talking about living with your market
value way more than minimum weight so if
you have anybody that keeps bringing up
the minimum wage debate say watch this
video and tell me what you think about
it right now two videos I want you to
watch if you're watching the same path I
really do want to increase my market
value but I want to go a little bit
deeper I've got two videos I want you to
watch one is how to reach your full
potential I was asked this question and
I said I'm gonna take a deep dive on
explaining this topic on how to reach
your full potential this is a deep dive
however it's pretty direct and you may
not like some of it because I'm going to
be talking about the truth with you and
it's gonna hurt so here the first one is
how to reach your full potential the
other video I want you to watch is seven
Habits that I help you dominate in 2019
so those are the two videos I'm gonna
give you a PDF of today's video if you
text seven four seven two six zero eight
four six one again Texas at seven four
seven two six zero eight four six one
and we will send you the PDF of today's
episode you can really look at all the
numbers that maybe I skipped through a
little bit fast in this episode having
said that if you haven't subscribed
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye